in the context of a loan what do we say
most like really large loans are for
usually forgetting like a car or a house
or that kind of thing
so portability what that refers to is
are you able to like I borrowed this
amount of money but can I put that over
to buy something else okay so for
example I've bought a house okay
and your light and the baby's like sure
will give you X amount of dollars for
that and then at some point even that
time for you and you're like actually
I'm gonna sell this house and buy
another one with this amount of money
that I borrowed from you okay so this is
like transferring over that debt for a
different purpose okay now you think
about it for the point of view of the
bank why might you be not okay with
people doing that okay yeah that's right
so the first thing is like well this is
all under contract right so I'm not just
gonna go back on that but you know you
can see some people are quite willing to
do it they'll pay you a fee the risk is
um let's come back to me filing
bankruptcy okay if I file bankruptcy and
I'm like sorry I know I are everyone in
this room money but um sorry guys
can't do it okay you're actually gonna
say hey hold on we're not gonna let you
out that easy you know and to say a
whole the debts caught on you're gonna
be able to say look I have assets that
can be sold to get that money back right
have you guys had a repossession
possession so it's like hey I have all
this stuff and you guys have the right
as my creditor the bank has the right is
your creditor to sell off your staff to
be able to make that money back okay now
think about this you agreed I'll borrow
the money I'll buy this house right the
bank is looking at you and checking your
hand and smiling but behind their back
they're like yeah great but that house
that you're buying I'm gonna sell it if
you declared bankrupt right why will
they sell it that's how they'll recover
the debt right now if you if you say hey
it's cool I know I bought I know we
agreed to buy that house I like to buy
this really do you want to Terry now is
that okay
they're not gonna be okay with that
because they're not
necessarily guaranteed to get their debt
back does that make sense so they're
like yeah you want to do that that's not
for free that's that's we want to check
we want to say that what it is out and
make sure that that house you're pouring
this mortgage over to he's actually
going to repay our death does that make
sense so that's kind of like an
administrative fee if you like yeah okay
cool let's talk about these two together
these two despite sounding very
different are actually the same thing
basically okay have a look yeah question
oh yes sure okay so portability when it
says like $300 that's how much they're
going to charge you that's how much
they're gonna charge you if you want to
transfer your mortgage pain of this
house versus it's paying off some other
object like a different house or a
different piece of land or a different
car or something like that a repair
quality and parental leave I know they
sound very different but when you have a
look at the answers to each of them you
see remarkable similarities they are the
same thing he's your definition for each
of them a repayment holiday or parental
leave is basically you say to the bank
hey can I take some temporary time off
from paying this loan can I take some
temporary time off of some fixed amount
that will agree to like saying oh I
don't know a year that's how maternity
leave works that kind of thing can I
take a year off for making the unit
payment you'll keep on calculating
interest I promise I'll come back I'm
good you can check my credit history
donor ah but can I have a period of time
when hey for example I'm on holidays I'm
not earning money here so I can't make
these repayments or I've just had a
child I am I've got to stop working or
I've got to work on a part-time basis
and I just can't make this 1888 dollars
a month can I agree to a temporary
amount of time some number of weeks and
months where payments just stop right
you I still owe you stuff and the
increase interest is still going but can
I have a break
okay honeybees like that forget that
okay Oh or no-frill says you want to pay
for the privilege is that wrong sir
you can see why by the way you're like
oh look over here right look at that
straight look at the top line and we
look to be said man that ain't just
right why would anyone in their right
mind choose a bank account with a higher
interest rate than all these other ones
they're gonna make you pay through the
nose for that right remember how much of
a difference it made little percentages
well the reason you go for a higher
instrument these guys is because you get
all of these benefits along with it does
that make sense so you need to make a
decision for yourself and think oh okay
does this matter to me is this an
important feature to have on my bank
note well then I'd better pay for it
right there's such thing as a free lunch